hi everybody and welcome to the second
video on a series that shows you how to
build an 8 ball pool game with
JavaScript and html5 in the last video
we implemented a shoot method on both
the stay class and the ball class so
that when we'll release the left button
on our mouse it will shoot the ball
towards the position of the pointer and
we also display the shooting animation
as you can see right here on the canvas
okay so now I'll open the vector to j/s
file and there I want to add a method so
I could get the length of a given vector
so vector 2 dot prototype dot length and
that will be equal function and here I'm
going to return the result of the length
formula on the given vector and I'm
going to calculate that using the math
object of JavaScript
[Music]
okay great
inside both yes I want to add another
property to the ball class that will
indicate whether the ball is moving or
not so this dog moving will be initially
false and inside the update method I
want to set it to be false if not this
dot velocity dot length is less than
let's say five so if that happens I want
to set this dot moving to be false and
before that I want to set this dot
velocity to be a new vector2 so it's x
and y values will be zeros and inside
the chute method after I change the
velocity I want to set this dot moving
to be true and I'm going to add another
property to the stick class and I'm
going to call this property this dot
shot and initially it will be false
maybe I can find a better name but for
now that will do and inside the chute
method I want to set this dot shot to be
true and inside the game world will
implement another method that I will
call game world prototype dot balls
moving and that will be equal function
and for now we only have one ball that
this object contains so we'll return
this dot white ball that moving inside
the update method so if all the balls
start moving so if this dot balls moving
and
[Music]
if this dot stick that shot is true so
sorry if not this dot poles moving I'll
call a method inside the stick object
that I will name reposition and I will
send this dot white ball dot position so
I want to reposition the stick to the
new position of the white ball so let's
open stick G yes again and here I'm
going to implement this method stick the
prototype door three position and that
will be equal function that will get a
position as an argument and it will set
this dot position to be a copy of this
position the the position argument and
I'm going to set this dot origin to be
equal the stick origin constant a copy
of it now back in the browser let me
refresh and once the ball stops moving
the stick changes its position to be the
same as the new position of the white
ball just one final thing before we move
on on the reposition method that we just
wrote let's set this dot shot to be
false and let's see that everything
still works as it should okay great in
assets dot yes let's load some more
sprites so the first one will be the
sprite of the red ball and the second
one will be the sprite of the yellow
ball and the last one will be the sprite
of the black ball now I will create a
new file that will go by the name of
color a yes and there I'm going to
define something that we call in other
languages and enum and it will contain
all the different colors that we use on
our game so red yellow black and white
and each color is going to have a
different value
back in assets dodge ASI will implement
a helper function that will provide me
the sprite that I want based on the
color that I will send it so I will call
this function get ball sprite bicolor
and it will get as an argument a color
and here I'm going to create a switch
case statement so switch color and in
case the color is color dot red I will
return the red sprite okay so I filled
it up with the rest of the colors and
now we can go to the ball class and
change the function constructor so it
will get a color as an argument and here
I'm going to set the sprite this dot
sprite to be get ball sprite bicolor and
send the color that we got as an
argument and here in the draw method we
can just delete sprites dot white ball
and send this dot sprite instead so now
we have to go back to the game world and
to send the color that we want for the
white ball which is of course white and
let's go to the index.html file and add
a reference to the colored ojs file that
we just wrote so script SRC and that
will be equal color yes back in our
browser everything still works fine in
purpose of testing let's change the
color to be red and let's refresh the
browser and that also works great so
let's change it back to be white as we
want it to be okay so let me place a bit
of code here because I don't see the
point of writing it all again what you
see here in front of you is an array
that contains
all the different arguments that we need
in order to create our ball objects so
you can see that each element in this
array is actually a pair that contains a
position and a color and eventually we
use the map function in order to take
every parameter and to pass it into the
ball function constructor to create a
new ball
so at the end of the day what you get is
that this dot balls contains all the
balls other ball objects that we need in
our game so down here instead of
creating a new object for the white ball
member we can just refer it to the last
object in the array that we just created
and maybe we'll change it in the future
but for now that will do and down here
in the update method we can just loop
over this array and write for a lat I
equals 0 I is less than this dot ball
and I plus plus and to call this dot
balls at i dot update and to send the
Delta of course and let's copy that and
paste that on the draw method so we can
loop over the array and instead of
calling the update method we can call
the draw method so back in our browser
finally you can see that our setup at
least visually is pretty much complete
and if I'll shoot the ball towards any
direction really as soon as the white
ball stops moving the stick repositions
itself to the new position of the white
ball ok so there's something that I need
to fix before we move on now that we
have more Ball objects it's not enough
to
check only if the white ball is moving
on the balls moving method we want to
loop over the array and to see if any of
the ball object is moving so I will set
a new boolean both moving to be false
and let's loop over the array this dot
balls
dot length hi plus plus and if this dot
balls at I is moving we can set balls
moving to be true and we can break out
of the loop now we will return balls
moving back in our browser let's see
that everything still works yeah that
looks fine now in vector to dodge a yes
we'll need to add some more operations
to support the collision system that
we're going to implement later on so
we'll add here a new method so vector to
dot prototype dot add and that will be
equal that will get another vector and
we're just going to return a new vector
that will be the sum of both vectors so
this dot X plus vector dot X and this
dot y plus vector dot y
[Music]
let's add another one and let's call
this one subtract and here I will return
the subtraction result of this of the
vector argument from this vector and the
last one for now will be the dot product
so vector two dot prototype dot dot that
will be equal a function that will get
another vector and this function will
return the result of a dot product
operation between both vectors so that
will be this dot X multiplied by a
factor that ax plus the star Y
multiplied by vector dot Y now let's go
to our game world and there on the
update method before we do anything we
want to check if collisions occur so
let's write a new method for that and
let's call it on the update method let's
call this method this dot and all
collisions so game world dot prototype
dot handle collisions and that would be
equal function and inside this function
I want to loop over the array in a
certain manner that will provide me all
the possible pairs of objects so for let
I equals 0 is less than this dot both
docklands I plus plus and inside the
nested loop I'm going to declare let J
be I plus 1 J is less than this dot
balls
dot length I and I plus bus
[Music]
okay so inside this loop let's get the
first ball out of the array so first
ball that will be equal this dot balls
at I and Const second ball and that will
be equal this dot balls at J and I want
to write something like first ball dot
collide with second ball and of course
we need to implement this method in
order for that to work let's see that
everything is fine here
mmm oh actually I have a mistake inside
the nested loop and we need to increase
J so J plus plus okay so now let's
implement the collide with method inside
the ball class so both prototype dot
collide with and that will be equal that
will get a ball as an argument okay so
this is the moment we all have been
waiting for elastic collision in two
dimensions and before I begin I must
give a huge credit to Chad berchik who
wrote an article about this subject in
2009 and this article explains
everything in a very simple manner and
even if you don't have a mathematical
background I really encourage you to go
and read this article I will leave a
link in the description down below and
really it's very easy to read and it's
it explains everything just beautifully
so go and read this article one more
thing that I want to say before we begin
is that I'm going to provide you with
steps on how to implement elastic
collision in your code but I'm not going
to get too deep inside the mathematical
proofs and concepts okay so now that we
are all set let's begin step 1 finding a
unit normal vector a unit normal vector
is a
that has length of one which is
perpendicular to the surfaces of the
balls at the point of the collision in
order to find the unit normal vector we
need to find a normal vector first and
we can do that by subtracting one of the
balls position from the other balls
position so back in our code in the
collide with method let's find a normal
vector and let's scroll down a little
bit so it will be easier to see okay
that's better so Const N and that will
be equal this dot position except
subtract and we'll send ball dot
position from this normal vector we can
also get the distance between the
Centers of both balls and this will
indicate us where whether a collision
occurred or not so let's find the
distance and let's set const dist to be
n dot length and if the distance is
greater than the ball's diameter then we
want to return from this function
because there is no collision between
both balls let's not forget to set
another constant that will call ball
diameter and in our case that will be 38
okay so now let's find a unit vector of
N and we can do that by taking n and
multiplying it by 1 divided by its
length okay so now back in our code
let's write a new comment and we'll
declare here that
here we're going to find unit normal
vector let's set Const UN to be n
multiplied by 1 divided by n dot length
[Music]
step to finding the unit tangent vector
back to the drawing you can see that the
unit tangent vector is a vector that has
a length of 1 and is tangent to the
surfaces of the balls at the point of
the collision we can find it by using
our unit normal vector that we already
found we just take the x-value to be
minus u and dot Y and the Y value of the
unit tangent vector to be un dot X back
in our code let's write a new comment
finding unit tangent vector and we'll
set const UT to be a new vector to
object that it's x value will be minus
UN dot y and is its Y value will be un
dot X step three resolving the
velocities into normal and tangential
components so we were doing that by
performing a dot product operation
between the velocities of the balls and
the UN and UT vectors that we already
found back in our code let's write a
comment project velocities onto mm the
unit normal and unit tangent vectors
okay let's go one by one
so const v1n and that will be equal UN
dot this dot velocity const v1 t and
that will be UT dot this dot velocity
[Music]
const v2 n and that will be you and dot
bow dot velocity and finally const v 2t
and that will be equal UT dot bow dot
velocity step 4 find new normal
velocities we want to find the normal
velocities after the collision and for
that we can use the formula for
collisions for elastic collisions in one
dimension and because both of our
objects have the same mass what we get
here is rather simple if we just put our
values inside we get that vtag v1 and
tag tag means after the collision will
be equals to will be equal to V 2 N and
V 2 n tag tag stands for after the
collision will be equal to V 1 and that
we already calculated in the previous
step so back in our code that will be
pretty easy to implement so let's just
write a new comment first find new
normal velocities and we'll set let V 1
and tag V equals V 2 N and let V 2 n tag
V equals V 1 n
five now we want to convert the scaler
normal and the tangential velocities in
two vectors and for that we need to make
some few multiplications between the
vectors and the unit normals and a unit
tangent that we calculated before so
let's go back to the code and implement
that so back in our code let's write a
new comment convert the scalar normal
and the tangential velocities into
vectors so V 1 and tag will be the unit
normal multiplied by V 1 and tag and
let's set const v 1t tag to be UT x v 1t
and let's set V 2 and tag to be equal u
n multiplied by V 2 and tag and let's
add Const V 2 T tag to be equals the UT
multiplied by V 2 T step 6 the final
step for now update velocities now we
need to update the velocities of our
ball objects according to the equations
that you see right here in front of you
so back in our code that's right and you
comment and that's right
update velocities yeah finally so let's
set this dot velocity to be
v1n tag ad v1 t tag and ball dot
velocity to be v2 and tag dot add v2 t
tag and now let's set this dot moving to
be true and let's also set ball dot
moving to be true okay so now back in
our browser let's test the results
I'm really excited let's see what
happens okay
hmm so we do have collisions but we also
have an issue here because you see that
the balls kind of merge together and
that's not good for us there is a way to
fix that and let's do that let's fix
that okay so back in our code we will
need to find a minimum translation
distance which is the minimum distance
that an object a colliding object can be
moved in order to not collide anymore
with the other object so Const minimum
translation distance MTD will be equal
the normal that we calculated before
multiplied by the ball diameter minus
the distance divided by the distance and
I should put this part in parentheses
okay so now let's push and pull the
balls apart okay so let's do that by
setting this dot position to be this dot
position dot add and I will add the MTD
multiplied by half
and I will set bow that position to be
the bordered position dot subtract MTD
multiplied by half okay so back in the
browser let's test the results and hey
whoa this is actually working so let's
try another one here yeah great okay so
even though the physics that we
implemented in this game are 100%
correct we still got an issue here let
me demonstrate
and let's see if you can spot it okay
did you get it let's watch that again in
slow motion here you'll see that at the
time of the collision some of the balls
overlap each other and that happens
because it detects the collision too
late when the balls are already on the
same area back in our code in order to
minimize that unwanted effect I will try
to tune some of the constants so let me
start with the Delta and let's set it to
be 1 divided by 177 and that's just a
number that I came up with and let me
just remind you that the Delta defines
how much of the ball's velocities we
will add to the ball's positions on each
iteration of the main loop now in the
boss update method we will multiply the
velocity by 0.984 in the part of the
code where we apply friction and let me
just write it in a comment so here we
apply friction and again you can choose
any number that suit your needs
back in our browser and now it looks
much better but since we decrease the
value of Delta it seems like the stick
doesn't hit the white ball with enough
power so back in our code inside the
increased power method of the stick
class we will increase every
by 120 and let's set a max power maximum
power so if this dot power is greater
than max power I want to return from
this function and let me just set const
max power to be for now 8000 now let's
check the result and mmm I don't know
maybe we'll change it to 7500 okay so I
think that's better
please take your time and tune those
numbers until you will get a result that
will satisfy you of course that's not a
perfect solution to the problem but that
will do for now if you want you can read
more about something called quadtrees
and how to use it for collision
detection but that's beyond the scope of
this tutorial inside the game world I'm
going to create a new member that I will
call table and this dot table will be a
new object literal that will contain the
x and y values of the borders of the
table so top y is 57 and the right x
value the right borders x value is 1443
and the bottom Y value is 768 and the
left borders x value is 57
[Music]
now inside the handle collisions method
inside the first loop I want to write
something like this dot balls at I dot
collide with and instead of sending a
ball I want to send a table the table
that we created so in order for that to
work I will create two more methods
inside the ball class and the first one
I will call ball dot prototype dot
collide with ball and that will be equal
a function that will get a ball as an
argument and the second one will be ball
dot prototype dot collide with table and
that will be equal a function that will
get a table as an argument so now let me
just copy all the content of the collide
with method that we wrote for ball two
ball collision and let me paste that
inside the collide with ball method that
we just wrote and here I'm going to
change the argument to be called object
instead of ball inside the collide with
method and I'm going to check if object
is instance of ball and if it is I'm
going to call the collide with ball
method and I'm going to send this object
and else I want to call this dot collide
with table and to send the object okay
so back in the browser we see that table
is not defined so let's go back to the
game world and instead of sending table
we need to send this dot table and let's
check again so again tables not defined
and this time it's on the collide with
method so here I sent
accidentally table instead of object so
let's go back to the browser and let's
refresh and see that everything still
works yeah it does so back in our code
in the collide with table method the
first thing I want to do is to check if
the ball is moving and if it's not I
want to return from this function next I
will set a new variable that I will call
collided to be false and before I move
on I need to create a new constant that
I will call the ball radius and it will
be half of the balls diameter now I want
to check if this dot position dot Y is
less or equal to the table dot top y
plus the ball radius and if that happens
I want to set the velocity to be a new
velocity that its x value will be the
same x value of the previous velocity
and its Y value will be minus this dot
velocity dot Y and I want to set
collided to be true now let's test the
results on the browser and that looks
like it's working so now let's do the
same thing for the right border so this
should be X instead of Y and this should
be right X instead of top Y and this
should be greater or equal and this
should be minus I hope you guys are
following and here instead of
- this dot velocity does why I need to
make the x value to be minus the x value
of the previous velocity so now let's
refresh the browser and test the right
border and that seems like it works so
back in our code we need to do the same
for the bottom one and the left one so
let's start with the bottom and that
should be greater or equal and this
should be bottom Y and that should be -
the ball radius and the code inside
should stay the same so let's refresh
and let's test and that looks fine so
now the last border let me copy that and
paste that here and instead of greater
should be less than or equal to left x +
ball radius and same here we don't need
to change the code inside the if
statement let me just refresh the
browser and let's see and yet all the
borders collisions are working so one
final thing that i want to do inside
this method is to decrease the velocity
in case of collision
so if collided so this dot velocity will
be this dot velocity multiplied by zero
point nine eight to simulate energy loss
okay so let's test the results let me
refresh and let's shoot the white ball
towards other balls and hurry so you can
see that we pretty much finished
implementing the physics for this game
i'm sure there are still some bugs here
and there but we'll find them on the go
and we'll fix them all and this was it
for this video thank you very much for
watching
and stay tuned for more good bye